i said this session is being video and
audio recorded
the recording will subsequently of which
is it's needing to be placed online
um and as you can see on the screen to
your left for most of you
and the front of the room this is what i
expect you to see if you're on the
general court website where it is being
live streamed
this is not a typical meeting of the
house or senate committee and it's not
being attended so you know by all
members of
the house committee we have members of
both the house and senate with
us here tonight um and i would like to
defer to senator graves here from the
senate and if the senate could introduce
themselves
i am senator gray i am the chair of the
senate select committee on redistricting
good evening um i am senator sharon
carson i represent senate district 14
which is londonderry president of auburn
i am the chair of senate judiciary and
senate executive department
administration
i'm state senator john soucy i represent
senate district 18 comprised of ports
549 manchester in the town of litchfield
thank you senators
do we expect senator perkins boca to
arrive shortly so
instead of going reintroducing her when
she gets here
thank you senator
we do have members of the house special
committee on redistricting with us my
name is carla griffin i'm a
representative from goffstown i am chair
of the redistricting
committee in the house of
representatives and i'm going to ask the
representatives that are with us tonight
from the committee to introduce
themselves and i'd like to start down
there
hello
uh
you ma'am sure representative name is
matt wilhelm i'm the student
representative for folksboro district 42
i'm state representative ross barry i uh
represent uh the southern half of the
county district 4 town of barrington i'm
a member of the labor and committee
finance committee this committee and
senior advisor in the house majority
office
pittsfield
[Music]
i serve on the judiciary committee in
addition to the special committee on
redistricting
thank you members for introducing
yourself to being with us all here
tonight
um before we actually begin i want to
speak to the overall process that we're
going through particularly in the houses
that is the
committee that i am sharing and
put this together
information on the redistricting process
for the house of representatives can be
found on the general report website and
for some of you here i don't know that
but i know that this is being live
streamed and it will be reported and
people will be looking at it at a later
date once you get on the general court
website you would click on the house of
representatives
there are more committees than you can
imagine it operating
by the legislature here in concord and
you want to go to the standing committee
and then scroll down to the special
committee on redistricting when you
click on that you're going to find a
list of all the members
you're going to find some contact
information you're going to be able to
email all the members of the
redistricting commission by clicking on
a link there and there's also a link to
the committee website
and that page when you when you go to
that page it has additional information
particularly on redistricting there will
be there is a link for meetings
and minutes on that page and that is the
page where i inspect the link for this
maps can be found on that page and i'll
be talking to it about that we sort of
did some beta testing and i'll make sure
that there's something there that people
want to submit as you can upload
um so what are the maps for and what are
we doing here i think all of you here
know we're redistricting redistricting
and it's a process that goes on every 10
years it's done after the federal census
and that population data is used to
create districts for all level of
government in regards to the
representation here in new hampshire the
constitution says that the
responsibility for the creation of those
districts is that of the legislature
which is why your members of your senate
and your house are here before you
the districts that we will be redrawing
in new hampshire
are the congressional district the
executive council seats the state senate
seats and the state representatives
there's also redistricting for county
commissioners districts and delegates to
the state party convention i know that
most of you have got one of the handouts
that we've got here tonight that
information provides you with more
detail on where about coming that is how
many we are in tonight
you'll find a sheet with the population
data for the towns
and you'll also find a sheet that shows
the population data for the counties you
may have heard in the news that there
are a couple counties where the
will change a blue sign-up sheet i have
a sign-up sheet here for people to sign
up who want to speak and if you have
written information that you'd like to
submit um we have somebody here to take
it and we will make sure that all
members of the community on both sides
see it
and of course
remember because we are reporting it's
important to speak up i of course
remembered that after all the members of
the table did not speak into the
microphone
but it will also be picked up for the
recording which will then be accessible
to people online and then finally i have
um you are in the old merrimack county
courthouse
i was actually very sad when they built
the new courthouse because this
courthouse is one of the most beautiful
in the state
um i hope you've had an opportunity to
the benches that were in these
courtrooms were truly beautiful
and to remind you that indeed it isn't i
probably haven't been in this courthouse
as an attorney for over 15 years and
when i called about it i said is the
elevator still the same
and they say yes you want to take the
stairs
here we are i want to thank you all for
coming and
without any further flattering from the
chair here we'll get started and we're
looking forward to hearing from you and
the first person i have and i'm going to
[Music]
um
there was no statement of shared
versions of purpose and performing on a
democracy's key tasks
it's a little sense of collegiality with
bipartisanship i have no detailed
inclusive outline process
i heard
i've heard leadership dismiss about the
need to have public hands after the
proposed maps are already
that is probably the most important
because i would miss a demonstration of
the software which for which i'm very
thankful
um
obviously you'll be using i see no
reason why
several map versions couldn't be made
of november
when governors
needed a bipartisan
commission to do this task
assure us that the process would be
completely transparent
as citizens of democracy would be so
nothing
thank you mr
mcdonald ward
[Music]
gerrymandering is a tool that has been
used by political parties to ensure
rather than drawing reasonable
logical ones that recognize communities
of interest
they persuade themselves that their
gerrymandering
is bringing about a greater good
journalist sydney paris
have this to say about such mental
gymnastics
and i quote
once we assuage our consciences
by calling something
unnecessary
it begins to look more necessary
and less evil and reputational
the fact is that gerrymandering is wrong
pure and simple
the duty of the special committee is
please keep in mind
that citizens across the state
are closely watching the critical work
of this committee
question of you
yes
thank you very much just so everybody
knows representative smith knows i don't
always answer it but you can certainly
ask
i
am very honored to be here in uh
merrimack county tonight and what i
really hope that i will hear from the
citizens of marinette
is suggestions from them
about how
town city
wines should be drawn in the house and
the senate as they offend
merrimack
merrimack county
that is
at least what i had hoped to hear from
people um and uh rather than um
a more philosophical
discussion about the importance of
fair and transparent
i told no face
thank you representative smith we are
all free to say what we want and we all
have our own expectations thank you
thank you the next person i have signed
i have my show with sign up to speak on
really but i said i was not going to be
speaking
oh i'm sorry
written
oh
okay
nancy marshy
marcion
nancy i'm sorry how are you
[Music]
members of the um committee as a
resident of new london and as moderator
for the town of viewers for 25 of my
years living here i have an active
commitment to the value of each vote of
qualified voters
thank you for this opportunity to offer
public comments on redistricting which
will determine how every financial vote
will be valued for the next 10 years of
our lives
in 2010 of 150 communities eligible for
their own representative
62 were not assigned there
although new london had 4
397 listeners in 2010
when the required number was 3
it was not assigned its own district or
its own representative
now in 2021
every community with a population of 3
or higher is constitutionally guaranteed
its own district and represented
the london's population is 4 400.
[Music]
and other eligible towns so that they
are assigned the representative they are
legally too
please also pay quality attention to
proteins
assuring your closeness and shared
interests of their crowns as i drive to
playing field each year to moderate for
the legal women voters of new hampshire
candidate forum for the prokaryote which
includes our neighbor sunday
what does that say about the lack of
even physical closeness in that plateau
history
um our center is from boston
previously
in the ten years before this time
it was the western area of the state
which has
[Music]
more advantage of getting it insider in
that area
so if i had a comment about senate
particularly in my area
i just think it's
[Music]
um
he reflected all that is unethical in
partisan germany
you have the opportunity to do what you
were elected to do
serve the citizens of new hampshire by
assuring each voter that their long hope
comes in
thank you for this opportunity
to urge non-partisan decision making my
little committee so the dancer can be
proud of 2021
submitted in the expectation that the
[Music]
thank you did you want to submit that
i'll submit a copy and i'll send an
thank you
next signed up to speak is
[Music]
foreign
um
[Music]
to thank you for
um
[Music]
but we all know
an equal right to vote depends upon this
diligence complying districts as fairly
as possible
means that a party with fewer than 3 in
10 voters as members
does not dominate every legislative body
passing the most extreme budget in 15
years containing policies that most of
the people have been captured and
disagree
an equal right to vote means that the
desire of most people
to conserve energy minimize fossil fuels
[Music]
and cutting the interest in dividend
attacks forever will result in
politicians who support such actions
being turned on anonymous
this committee has the responsibility to
create districts that result in the will
of the people
being reflected in the actions of the
legislation
executive council and congressional
history
and i challenge you all to act with
integrity and uphold your constitutional
response
[Music]
thank you
next i have to speak up here please
tender
thank you madam chair liz tentarelli i'm
from newberry the westernmost town
in our wonderful state of merrimack
county
um
many people i've spoken with about
redistricting voice to concerns
that the process of drawing the maps be
done with transparency and public input
so i'm glad we're doing this meeting
and that the criteria the committee's
review clearly stated
therefore there are some questions that
i hope the committees will address
publicly in the coming weeks
obviously you'll adhere to the federal
and state constitutions about equal
representation
but what has your committee decided will
be an acceptable deviation from the
ideal numbers
for each of the four plans when will you
make that problem
nancy moratio already talked about the
uh towns that should have had their own
reps
so i wonder will your committee work to
make that happen
and where does adhering to that
constitutional requirements all in your
list of priorities
communities of interest is a broad term
but many are wondering which communities
of interest
your committee believes are important
considerations
when determining which towns should be
grouped together
have you set those priorities such as
keeping regional school districts in the
same senate district
or grouping neighboring towns that share
common problems such as water quality
issues or natural resources conservation
or public health issues
if you have not yet
prioritized those when do you expect to
set those priorities and will you make
them public on the committee's website
merrimack county is currently divided
among six senate districts
the towns in our county range from my
little town on the west to the cities of
concord and franklin
forming state senate districts it's
about the numbers of course but what
other demographic aspects will you be
considering
i suggest that until
draft maps are drawn and made available
to the public
it is an exercise and abstraction to
discuss what makes sense for any
particular town or city
therefore i suggest another round of
these county input sessions
where your actual draft maps will be
shown so that you can get specific
comments
from
municipal officials
and the public to be heard for your
consideration i want to thank you for
holding this first round of listening
sessions for creating a website where
this information will be available and
for your hard work on this important
decennial project and i will send email
testimony but i will give a copy thank
you
in a rabie
john really
sorry about that no that's quite
bad
[Music]
uh i'm not going to repeat particulars
of what other people have said in fact
i'm going to try to keep this very
straightforward
and simple
um my basic proposition is this
everybody
deserves an even chance to vote and an
eating chance to have his or her voice
heard
now
everybody in this room knows
that we live in a fierce
partisan contention
maybe generally speaking it's not rough
and in some unfortunate instances it's
gotten down like this
but we can stop that from happening
representative smith asked for
suggestions so we're going to put one to
you it's my personal suggestion i speak
for nobody else in this room
but here it goes
create an independent commission to
handle the district
as a legislature you can authorize it
you retain
your authority
over
redistricting thereby
at the same time
you ensure
an impartial
transparent process
which increases public trust
in our elections the alternative
in my view
is more wrangling
more roughness
more gerrymandering
more accusations of fraud
i could go on and on with the
particulars i'm sure you're aware of
what people have said on the subject
we don't have to travel that road
we can stop that code right now
so here's what i have to say just do it
thank you
[Music]
um
and not with you um this is my second
go-round this year of the election law
i've been on about a number of years and
you have some very dedicated public
um individuals here who participated in
the public process and i've had the
opportunity to spend a lot of time with
them in rooms in the legislative office
building so it's certainly not out of
any disrespect for you if i don't know
you and it's out of a lot of respect for
the time that the people in this room
are financially um in israel
speaking yes there are actually too many
hearings put on our
listening sessions going on at this time
the senate rules would say that you need
to repeat
not to
do a whole bunch of things okay
try to keep it concise
etc so
you know if
he doesn't go on too long or about
something
uh i am in the sense i will object
and try to get someone else to
[Music]
um and just so
i had received word that someone else
was going to be here to was the director
which is a non-partisan organization
that hosts redistricting data um
nationally
i also volunteer with open democracy
to say that redistricting is the
foundation of a democracy and if we um
break that foundation with
gerrymandering
seriously our democracy as we
are seeing um in the past
so the first to get into uh some of the
maps um
first congressionally uh i would ask
that you try to keep the
current congressional districts as uh
they are pretty considered to be very
fair
they have a lot of rural and they both
have a lot of urban so they're very well
put together
there is some
changes that could be made to enhance
those maps but i would think that the
cores of those maps should be kept
together in that um
they're actually very they're considered
to be very uh very good uh
districts for both
parties uh then moving on to the
executive council um i feel that the
executive council map should be
from the current districts and district
we should first start with um
almost like a regional approach approach
to the executive council seeing as we
have
kind of specific regions in new
hampshire we have the north country we
have the lake street we have western new
hampshire we have the sea coast
and then we have southern new hampshire
if we can break those uh start with
those different
areas with our executive council mass
we can get a better
representation of those areas um
and then concerning all of the different
maps i would uh
like to repeat that communities of
interest are very important and
they should be
preserved as
much as possible
for instance sauss
public health
those should be
kept together if possible i know
i've done a lot of mapping and i know
the map is difficult in some areas but
it is possible to
you you're not going to have the perfect
map but you can strive for the perfect
map um
and so uh i guess then moving on to the
senate
i would consider not a very good map in
that it
is
very there's a lot of different
sprawling uh districts i would ask the
committee to
keep
maybe when you're setting your criteria
to include compactness in those criteria
for the senate maps specifically
and i think that that could help
keep more communities of interest
together and we
include compactness as a
criteria
um
and then
for the
house map
this is where the kind of core of my uh
uh
speech is coming in um
so
i want to talk about the methodology in
calculating the
districts for the house um a little bit
of history on it in 2000 the house maps
were drawn and they were drawn using the
aggregate method um which is kind of
what everyone thinks the floaterial is
you kind of take two districts
and then there's a leftover population
from those districts you put them
together and you get a material
out of those leftover people which is
what is generally considered
uh
what i think whatever they think of as
but in actuality in
2002 uh the maps were challenging the
court and the supreme court ruled that
the aggregate method was not a valid
method in creating materials
because of the fact that you could say
have
two districts one district had say 50
extra people and one district had three
thousand
three hundred and fifty extra people
and then you could create a material out
of that using the agriculture
uh that that was unconstitutional based
on the one person one vote
and so that
floaters should therefore
consist of around the same amount of
people so for instance
uh
if a district if districts were three
thousand people you should have about
fifteen hundred from each district would
comprise your district and therefore
it would
in um with the one person one vote
um
and so what they put forth is what is
and in that what it does is it
assigns
the ideal population to the
non-coaterial
districts
and then
it takes the leftover population and
then pretty much tries to make sure that
those align given a certain deviation
um
i have uh
uh come up with a
different methodology
slightly um because the component is
very uh
it really limits the um
the amount of uh districts that can
actually use the floater so for instance
hudson and pelham currently are in the
same district they could not be broken
up into two different districts and with
a floaterial rep
because they would not align with the
component at that time
um
there's a number of other different uh
instances where this is the case and
so
given that in 2006 the
numerator constitution has changed to
give each
town that has a sufficient population
their own district um i think that it is
worth looking into different
methodologies um in calculating
materials to allow for more
towns have their own representatives
what i come up with is
what i call the alternative component
method which is pretty much the same
thing
as the component method
but what it does is it takes into
account
the deviations of the non-clotarial
uh
reps so for instance um
i sent the house committee a memo that
kind of outlines this uh more
clearly
it's a little difficult to
explain without a without a whiteboard
but um
but so for instance if uh say we have a
district say the ideal population for uh
house rep was three thousand feet um say
we have a district of four thousand
people and a district of five thousand
people um
you would have
the phone amendment would assign three
thousand people
in one district a house crowd three
thousand people in the other district
house and then there would be two
thousand people left over in one
district and one thousand people left
over in the other district
the component method calculates this and
says that there's a difference one
thousand people in that literal district
and therefore it's not allowed it's too
much it's too big of a dis too big of a
difference to allow
but what it doesn't calculate is that
there's a variation in those
non-coaterial
so for instance in the town that has
in the district that has 4000 people
you could assign
um between
three you could assign 3 000 people plus
or minus 5 so there's still an extra
deviation there so what you could do is
assign 2 850 people and then it would
provide 1 250 people to the plateau rep
and then with the
district with 5000 people you would
assign you could assign 3 150 people for
the nonprofit rep and they would they
would give 1
and therefore you're off by only
700 instead of a thousand and that would
that difference is actually close enough
to allow for a floater
um and so
what the alternate method alternate
important method really does is it
allows flexibility in the different
in the mapping of the house districts um
for instance um i know uh representative
mcguire is in a plateau with uh
epsom pittsfield and downstone
and with the current populations the uh
founds town if
that same district was kept together the
component method would not allow for out
for epsom and pittsfield to have their
own press um so
uh pittsfield and epsom would be kept
together and then allentown could have
its own red but with the alternative
performance he gives it just a little
bit of flexibility and then that would
allow for um pittsfield to have its own
[Music]
uh
in keeping with the same
um
spirit of the supreme court ruling in
that you can't have
three thousand people assigned to one
and fifty from another but it actually
uh gets just a slightly bit more uh
flexibility so for instance um the the
best possible uh
house map that that we could come up
with for merrimack had six violations um
for the current 2020
mapping um in 2010 there was 11 uh
violations of
towns that had this mission population
that did not get their own prep um
so
uh
with the alternative component method
you could actually get that out of two
so instead of six violations of the best
possible
method you get it down to two and those
two are actually um
one of the faults of my town in texas
and
so we need to be combined with one of
them and so we violate the constitution
luckily canterbury is also one so we
could uh combine those with loudoun and
that would only lead to one violation um
the other violation the other town that
dunbarton
so that they all have their own
um representation
and in keeping with the constitution and
i believe it would
keep in line with what the supreme court
um
[Music]
about the submission of maps um there is
supposed to be a link on the website for
people to be able to
upload maps um
it's not there so
i'll be communicating with staff and
frankly
[Music]
and i would be more than happy to come
i want to thank you for the transparency
of tonight's listening session
and also um
individuals deserve a chance after the
maps are created to also be public
comments
um as we've talked about a little bit
tonight it's really important that the
criteria is um publicly available so we
know how you are going to select
districts for county lines to be
followed
will we follow the constitution the 2006
amendment where towns with a large
enough population
um stay together
what communities of interest will you
select
school district would be one that i
think is really important and um the
open democracy mapping team has created
with the department of um
education an overlay that you can
overlay
the school districts and so there is a
tool available
um to overlay school districts if you
want to see which maps across school
districts the other communities of
interest
that's really important is a lot of
communities share police and fire
services
and and oftentimes those are separated
so for one example um in this city of
franklin the city of franklin ward 3 is
connected with north
north they share a state representative
northfield is large enough to have their
own state under the constitution
northfield shares a police station with
tilton
northfield can be combined because
they're in different counties get that
for the house maps but i think we need
to sort of think about
those districts i do want to bring up
another problem that i think
is just a timing problem with the census
delay this year is the city of franklin
has to change our chart to change
the population for 2020
is not an even population in the city of
franklin so the three ward lines will
need to be adjusted
our elections are october the first
tuesday of october so this
tuesday october 5th there will not be a
charter amendment
won't happen until
2022 where a charter amendment is
brought
i know that it's after this committee
has done their work so in its instances
like the city of franklin it would be
really great if you keep the city of
franklin together
as much as possible right now the city
of franklin works one and two are
divided with hill for
two state reps
and
ward three and northfield are two state
reps and then there's a larger float
area which is we have a representative
from loudoun that represents the
district there so as long as you can try
to try to keep all three works together
um
when the city does our work changing
charter
the
lines
will not be thrown off too much because
right now your math is
um
word three is our largest board in our
city with the 2020 numbers and the city
of franklin's charter has not been
amended
because the last two redistricting
we haven't seen growth
um and this this time our reports do
uh require changing
so that is another thing to look at the
process of how you
know you have to do your work and meet a
deadline um and study charters
in some instances in the instance of
frankly will not be done
before the work of this committee is
done so figuring out how you
reconcile those differences it would be
good to
reconcile those differences and
and get input from from leaders in those
communities
on
so i want to thank you again for for
this process um
i do want to touch a little bit on the
executive council line i know the city
of franklin is the northern part of that
executive council district we've lost
population
stay in a dragon shaped form but i think
as you look at the effects of council
maps it would be really good to keep the
criteria of compactness
and also
you can't get there from here in some
square towns you have to drive out of a
community
several miles outside of the community
to get somewhere so you should also look
at the major east-west highways that we
have
because sometimes you just stink it from
one town to another even though they're
next to each other so um those
geographical differences should be done
carefully and driving those steps
um i will talk about the
professional district maps that will be
drawn i do think
that the
to have a population
deviation of core from left side is
remarkable that you've got pretty equal
population in those two districts and so
to keep as much equal population as
possible but to try not to split county
lines i think hampton is an example
where
is the only community that's not in a
county line and not just in
congressional maps so it will be good to
look at trying to keep
the existing map
i will say that
the congressional maps are probably the
only maps you should do that with
the other maps trying to look at how the
gerrymandering was done 10 years ago and
say oh let's try to do something similar
without reconciling that
the districts were skewed
maybe a lot of process might be better
to sort of start from scratch in some of
the instances where we know existing
oh
[Music]
um
yes
[Music]
um
i think that
going
[Music]
many speakers here today
have suggested it's just the right thing
[Music]
you know democratic
leaning districts uh more than
republican or independent ones
but i
asked myself as a lawmaker
what's the best thing for grand speakers
uh it isn't my part bipartisan my
partisan is
uh
it should be the interest of everyone
um
if it is controlled by the people who
represent
republicans and democrats at a
disproportionate level that isn't
helping the state
if you don't include voices that
are independent
that is not the best interest of the
state we have a high percentage of
undeclared voters
and they deserve a voice
decisions should not
[Music]
in the state
has a voice has a representative has a
an executive counselor has a member of
congress a state senator and all the
other
offices that uh they get to choose
represent them fear
not one party
over another
certainly not
it should be independent and safe
to get more specific on some things that
i see
currently that are unfair the easiest is
i think that
[Music]
um
and it was done to neutralize democratic
power
[Music]
and i will say i've learned to come
around on this view thanks to
representative smith's leadership on
this
um
she has really risen above
uh
[Music]
um i also want to say that
i don't believe we should have materials
i think that
state representative districts as best
as possible
uh should be
only represented by one person
and the nativeness throughout the state
currently exists first the people of the
granite state
my uh district
the district i represent
um
it has about 4 400 people pretty compact
a lot of renters senior housing
um
[Music]
i notice that's not nearby
means that
with three times the voters does this
mean that that representative has more
power than me i would say represent your
friends of course has more power than
these
very good reasons but um
but across the state
should we look at it that way
shouldn't we think about
what is in the best interest of voters
to know that they're represented by a
state representative that all of the
candidates have a fair system an
affordable system
that isn't so large that they feel far
and so uneven
i just
[Music]
here
how
[Music]
um
uh
[Music]
um
the business
[Music]
we're currently in that district that
previously we have been in the same
cemetery
um
[Music]
that's all thank you
does the jury box deliver a verdict
[Music]
um
um i'm 36 i'm planning on living here my
entire life and
history has his eyes on what you all
have to aging over the last
weeks
i want you to know that
the
generation of activists that is coming
up the millennials
and
the younger kids
really care we're not jaded we're not
distracted by the internet
we are paying attention
very closely and whatever happens
please don't take a short view
[Music]
10 years from now but 20 30 40 50 years
from now and
what you do here will affect
what happens decades from now so please
please don't think about the next
election think about
40 50 years from now and what new
hampshire is going to look like
tonight i i really appreciate it this
was the first of our community
we have one scheduled next week in
stratfor
um
without a number of things that we will
be
[Music]
uh
um i just wanted to ask i i appreciate
very much the live streaming and
certainly the facility can accommodate
that i wonder if efforts are being made
to allow for people to testify
um
[Music]
we are setting up
a uh email address that will
get any input that is given to us via
that email
i believe it's going to be senate dot
redistricting
at
leg
state
and i'm not sure when it'll be set up i
expect it to be
in the next day or two
but optimistically tomorrow morning
[Music]
you